نداء عاجل ودعوة لاتخاذ إجراء بشأن
كوفيد 19.
منظمة الصحة العالمية تحث على
توخي الحذر الشديد
ضد رفع تدابير الصحة العامة تمامًا
عن فكرة أن الجميع
محميون وأن
كل شيء يعود إلى طبيعته
أعتقد الآن أنه افتراض خطير للغاية
في أي مكان في  العالم الذي
يدافع عن قادة العالم لحكومات العالم
يوم
الأربعاء في نفس اليوم تجاوز عدد القتلى العالمي من
19 المعسكر
4 ملايين وفقًا
لقادة الصحة العالمية بجامعة جونز هوبكنز قائلين إن الوباء
لا يزال مستشريًا
في البلدان ذات معدلات التطعيم المنخفضة
وأن رفع القيود
يضع  مناطق أخرى معرضة لخطر
انتشار المتغيرات ،
هذا ليس منحنى مسطحًا ، إنه
منحنى متزايد
يفترض أن الانتقال
لن يزداد
لأننا نفتح لأن
اللقاح هو افتراض خاطئ
سوف يزداد الانتقال عندما تفتح
هذا لأنه  يُطلق متغير دلتا
الإنذارات في جميع أنحاء العالم
، حيث شهدت المنطقة الأوروبية أ  زيادة بنسبة 33 في
المائة في حالات الإصابة بالفيروس في الأسبوع الماضي ،
ولكن على الرغم من المخاطر ، فقد خففت الولايات المتحدة
وإنجلترا القيود تدريجياً
مع
تخطيط إنجلترا لرفع معظم
قيود الفيروسات في 19 يوليو ،
لكن مع البلدان الأخرى التي لا تزال
تكافح مع تفشي شديد للعهد 19 ،
أكد المسؤولون الصحيون أن الدول
يجب أن نكون حذرين للغاية
حتى لا نفقد المكاسب التي تحققت في
مكافحة الوباء ،
فنحن نتابع انتشار هذا الفيروس في
جميع أنحاء العالم ونشهد
زيادات حادة في الحالات في العديد من
البلدان في الوقت
الحالي في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ستيف
ناناس